glenn greenwald has thought a lot about
that question greenwald is a traditional
leftist he's committed above all to
forcing transparency on people who hold
power
years ago greenwell co-founded a news
site called the intercept
today he resigned in a statement
greenwald explained why quote
the intercept's editors in violation of
my contractual right of editorial
freedom
censored an article i wrote this week
refusing to publish it unless i removed
all sections critical of democratic
presidential candidate joe biden
the candidate vehemently supported by
all new york-based intercept editors
involved in this effort at suppression
and he went on
greenwell's full statement is up tonight
at an internet platform called substack
which is not yet censored
no matter who you plan to vote for next
week we recommend that you read it
glenn greenwald joins us tonight glenn
thanks so much
for coming on the idea of you resigning
from
a news organization you helped found is
is is
stunning tell us why you did
well the news organization that i
co-created was in 2013 at the height of
the snowden reporting i left the
guardian to do it because i was seeing
that there were a lot of constraints
imposed on journalism
and their ability our ability to report
freely against governments against power
centers against
all kinds of institutions that wield
authority and the premise of the news
outlet
the core overarching premise the reason
it was created
was to ensure that journalists would
always have
complete journalistic independence and
editorial freedom
never have to pull punches
journalistically or pay homage to
pieties
because of the preferences the partisan
or ideological preferences of editors
or of anybody else that was the core
founding idea
and vision and then that is what makes
it so
amazing that at the very outlet that i
co-created that was built on my
reputation my credibility my
journalistic accomplishments
then tried to intervene to censor me six
days before an election
because i wanted to publish reporting
and analysis about the evidence that
raises serious questions
about the conduct of the candidate that
all of the editors at that outlet
vehemently and enthusiastically support
i would imagine that some of our viewers
don't read the intercept
you live outside our country which is
one of the reasons i think you say what
you think is true
tell us what this portends for the
future
here in the united states
so the intercept was actually for a
while a unique publication in and
and i think the vision i just described
as one reason but another was that
it was intended above all else to be
highly skeptical
of the claims of intelligence agencies
at the time when we were doing the
reporting
the attacks were coming from the nsa the
cia the deep state against me against my
source edward snowden against the
reporting
and we knew they were lying constantly
and disseminating propaganda in a very
powerful way so we set out to say
we're going to investigate them we're
going to be skeptical of them we're
going to subject their assertions
to critical scrutiny and i am so
embarrassed and angered that the media
outlet that
i created along with two other excellent
journalists to do that
the only article it published about all
of these documents that have emerged
about joe biden
other than a column of mine where i
denounced facebook and twitter for
censoring it
was an article that made reference in
passing to those documents very snidely
and dismissively to say that no one
should pay attention to it
because it was russian disinformation
and it cited a letter
from john brennan james clapper mike
hayden and the rest of the goons from
the cia in the intelligence community
asserting it and we're still that letter
said we have no evidence that russia is
involved in any of this
the intercept omitted that phrase simply
cited that letter to try and encourage
people
to ignore this evidence on the grounds
that russia had manufactured it and that
the evidence
was fabricated even though there's never
been any evidence for that that's been
true and everything since has disproven
it showing
russia was not involved in any of this
and nobody certainly not even joe biden
disputes that these emails are and other
text messages are completely real and
authentic
that's horrifying so what you're
watching is agencies of the us
government
turning their awesome and unconstrained
powers against the american population
this is the real story of the last four
years of the trump administration which
is that for a long time on the left
there was a healthy skepticism of the
cia
there was a lot of anti-war activism in
the bush and cheney years um
that has all disappeared and the reason
it's disappeared is because the cia
from the very first days of the trump
administration even before he was
inaugurated
devoted themselves to sabotaging the
administration because donald trump
questioned just a few of their pieties
and that can't be done in washington
whoever does that
must be destroyed and so the cia and the
deep state operatives
became heroes of the liberal left the
people who support the democratic party
they're
now in a full union with the neocons the
bush cheney operatives the cia silicon
valley
and wall street that is the union of
power along with mainstream media
outlets that are fully behind the
democratic party which is likely to at
least take over
one branch of government if not all of
them win the coming election
and that is a very alarming proposition
because they're authoritarian they
believe in censorship and they believe
in suppression
of information that exposes them in any
kind of a critical light
for a u.s government agency to try and
disseminate propaganda within the united
states i mean
is there any any clearer attack on
democracy than that
so when we were doing the snowden
reporting one of the things that brought
ed
induced edward snowden to come forward
as someone who had worked in the cia in
the nsa was his
anger and horror that the tools of the
nsa had been turned on the american
people they're supposed to spy on
foreign adversary governments but they
weren't
they were collecting our phone records
same with the cia
they're trained disinformation agents
that's what they do they lie for a
living but they're supposed to do that
in other countries where we want to
induce some sort of change overthrow our
government
topple a regime whatever quote unquote
interference the us government wants to
do the way we're all so upset that
russia did
in 2016 that's what they're trained to
do the law though
and the obvious foundational prohibition
on having a security state a national
security state after world war ii
was it was never supposed to be turned
domestically they weren't supposed to be
involved in our politics
or disseminating propaganda go turn on
any of those other cable networks or
pick up the op-ed page
of any of the biggest newspapers and all
you'll see are ex-members of the cia the
doj the fbi the nsa
telling americans what they ought to
believe they've infiltrated
the means of communication domestically
they do it through leaks they do it
through clandestine operations and
through lives they propagandize the
american people
in a way that is incredibly dangerous no
matter what your ideology
is i totally agree and i'm ashamed of
the times that i made apologies for
those agencies or this behavior i really
am you you are telling the truth
that's that's really clear glenn
greenwald congratulations on getting out
of there good to see you
thank you tucker appreciate it